una visita para dimensionar la
catástrofe de la sequía en el oeste de
eeuu la escasez de agua en la cuenca del
río colorado encendió las alarmas de
legisladores y comunidades afectadas el
agravamiento de la crisis de la sequía
en todo el oeste no sólo es malo para
las empresas y las explotaciones
agrícolas es una amenaza existente para
nuestras comunidades y nuestros medios
de vida la creciente crisis de la sequía
se ve alimentada por los impactos del
cambio climático incluyendo el calor
extremo la escases de precipitaciones y
a su vez las condiciones de sequías
severas perpetúan la crisis climática
aunque el diálogo continúa el martes los
7 estados que dependen del agua del río
colorado no lograron un acuerdo sobre
cómo utilizar el suministro del arroyo
cuyo caudal está cada vez más mermado
cuando miramos a esto no son sólo dos o
tres estados es una cuenca entera así
que las conversaciones que estamos
teniendo colectivamente son a través de
los estados que conforman esta cuenca
pero también hablamos con las
comunidades son decisiones difíciles
absolutamente difíciles de mantener lo
que puedo decirles es que el diálogo
está en curso el gobierno federal empezó
a recortar el suministro algunos estados
que prácticamente dejaron sin agua a
agricultores del centro de arizona
poniendo en jaque algunas cosechas que
dejan severas afectaciones
no creo que pueda subrayar lo lo
suficiente la alimentación es una
cuestión de seguridad nacional
permítanme repetirlo la alimentación es
una cuestión de seguridad nacional y
aquí en el valle sabemos que donde fluye
el agua crecen los alimentos a la espera
de nuevos anuncios sobre más
limitaciones al agua la situación del
río colorado es el claro reflejo de la
mega sequía que azota al oeste
estadounidense